the biden regime's energy response to
putin's war on ukraine has become a
completely demented fiasco you know the
details europe's dependent on russian
oil and gas if we were serious about
stopping putin we'd impose a worldwide
embargo on russian energy which is not
some sacrifice americans need to make
because we could in fact replace much of
russian energy with american energy but
biden won't do that because he's too
scared of the extremist climate zealots
who now run his party but look what this
tells us about biden and the democrats
about their character who they really
are they have a chance to help american
workers many of the exact type of
workers in exact places biden claims is
all about by boosting a vital sector of
our economy at the same time they could
help american consumers not just by
reducing upward pressure on gas prices
but with inflation generally since
energy is such a big component of
industries costs and at the same time as
all that they could hold putin's economy
below the water line and strengthen
america for the long term by making us
energy independent again they could have
done all of that but they chose not to
they chose to keep american energy
underground to kill american jobs and
raise american prices they chose to keep
putin's energy lifeline going they chose
to undermine our strategic position by
making us dependent on foreign energy
and they lied about it non-stop
now for the final humiliation the
foreign energy they're on their knees
begging for is from some of the world's
worst regimes including iran and
venezuela all of this in the name of
climate
when the foreign energy is dirtier than
u.s natural gas and they're closing down
our nuclear power stations that don't
produce carbon emissions at all
in all my years in politics and in
government i have never seen a more
stupid incoherent self-harming policy
from more shallow cynical and despicable
characters than this tell us what you
think it's steve hilton x an extreme fnc
and share this message when we post it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else